director HealthSouth mr. president this
problem in humans we have to do
something
has evolved their greatest threat has
returned can shield unite the secret
warriors who what in humans taking
action with shield to combat a danger
unlike any the world has ever seen
Marvel's agents of shield returns March
8th on ABC
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield secret Warriors
trailer we finally got to secret
warriors so let's break it down this is
really the best thing that could have
happened to the show if you don't know
anything about secret warriors it was a
Nick Fury team in the comics that the
big bad is Ward who has now possessed by
what it seems like is hive a villain
from the comics not surprisingly hive
was one of the big villains of that
secret warriors comic book
who the hell is higher than what's been
going on on agents of shield so far but
in this secret warriors storyline the
hive character was created in a lab by
Hydra to physically embody all of their
ideals and they they fed a host to it
they're just like here you go so it
consumed that and that's how it took
physical form later it ended up taking
control of madam hydras body so it
really functions more like a parasite so
now you kind of see what was going on
with the first half of agents of shield
they kept teasing people getting
sacrificed it on that foreign planet for
the hive beast itself has no real
personality it really just becomes the
sum total of all the personalities that
it assimilates when we see the ward
character again it's still basically
ward and it's kind of this amalgam
personality of all the beings that have
been sacrificed to it and as for powers
go I don't know exactly how crazy the TV
show is gonna get with this powers Peter
because as is crazy tentacles and
parasites that he can take people down
with using projectiles but he does make
whatever host that he inhabits stronger
the only weaknesses are weaknesses of
the original host so if you have some
rare genetic disability that will also
become a disability of the high creature
until it assimilates someone that's even
stronger so what I'm wondering is is if
they're gonna have hives start
assimilating the powers of other
Inhumans it can do that but it seems
that they're also giving it a level of
control like a level of social control
over other Inhumans they just been
teasing it is this big bad that's going
to lead a new world order a new Hydra
world order
now the secret Warriors team themselves
came around during Secret Invasion that
was a long time ago
that was right after Captain America's
Civil War civil war destabilized the
earth laid a foundation for the scrolls
to invade the original team was quake
slingshot Stonewall Eden fizzy the druid
Phobos in Hellfire so they're probably
gonna swap a couple characters from the
comic book team we already have quake
you know Daisy Johnson leading the team
really the first couple of episodes when
it comes back is gonna be them tracking
down new in here
slingshot is gonna be the first one to
join the team probably and Lincoln is
hardcore on the team now
so I feel like if you felt like the
first half of the season moves a little
slow right now the second half of the
season is when you need to start
watching now the episode doesn't air
like the first episode when it comes
back won't be till March 8th
I don't know when it starts again in the
UK so just check your local listings it
either airs on Sky or channel 4 I can't
remember which channel it's on in the UK
but if you have any friends that you're
trying to get into the show don't worry
about watching the old stuff just tell
them to start watching with the new
episodes if they know anything about
Marvel like they understand who that
some of the Marvel characters are
they'll totally be able to jump on board
shield is one of those shows that has a
good cast I feel like they have a lot of
stuff there that could make a really
good TV show there's just a couple of
things that they've waited on doing like
doing secret warriors that I feel like
they should have done a little bit
faster what about the crossover with
Captain America Civil War I'm expecting
it to be bigger than the Avengers age of
Ultron crossover last year last year was
really a Skype call crossover there's
been a lot of crazy stuff happening
behind the scenes in Marvel Studios the
film part of the business the TV studio
largely hasn't changed that much they
have the Netflix stuff going on which is
kind of its own thing they have the
network stuff going on on ABC agent
Carter season 2 sounds like it might get
cancelled I will probably do some sort
of video after the season is over I
didn't want to do videos for every
single episode but I did want to talk
about it a little bit it's a good show
it just doesn't fit in really well with
a lot of the other big popular Marvel
stuff I think it's just a lot harder for
shows that aren't very extreme to break
through the noise like daredevil for
instance it's gonna be super hardcore so
naturally everyone's gonna gravitate
towards it just be like oh my god this
is melting my face off look how amazing
the movies have a hundred and fifty
million dollars to spend on big crazy
effects and actors that cost 20 million
dollars a pop so when you take all those
things away it really is hard for a TV
show to be amazing but because we are
really close to Captain America Civil
War they're slowly ramping up stuff for
that so start expecting to see more and
more from that movie no I do not think
that we're gonna see spider-man anytime
soon I've seen a few behind-the-scenes
pictures that have seemed like
spider-man I don't know if they're
official and they're super spoilery so
I'm not gonna post them here but I don't
think we're gonna see spider-man in any
of the trailers that they continue to
drop
they'll probably be a couple more
trailers
tomorrow is gonna be new Game of Thrones
new Walking Dead so be sure to subscribe
to get those and then in another week or
two when we get a little bit closer to
daredevil coming out I'll start doing
more daredevil punisher videos in case
you guys didn't see it YouTube's been
kind of weird today with with uploads
being super slow but you can click here
for my Deadpool is Iron Man video the
writers Ryan Reynolds has just been
talking about the next couple of movies
and you can click here to learn all
about Ben Affleck changing the Batman V
Superman script thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you